Listen up!
Everyone is going to die.
Oh, not these people!
No, no, no, no!
Don't worry.
I mean, sure, one day, they will die.
We all will!
But the point is,
they all need
The Gentle Art of Swedish Death Cleaning.
What is Swedish Death Cleaning, you say?
Basically cleaning out your crap
so that others don't have to do it
when you're gone.
If you can’t keep track of your things...
you have too many.
When I'm done in here,
you're going to want to entertain.
It's about discovering what's important to you.
You can't save everything!
This is Ella!
This is an inflatable wiener.
Enough of this wiener talk.
I'm getting horn - hungry, I meant.
But they are here to make our lives better.
There's a lot of life in death.
The love gives you this kind of perspective,
this sharpness.
I don't want to live this way.
I need your help.
My mom really wants me to have this.
But you don't like it?
No I don’t.
Let your home be a reflection of you.
The toughest thing I ever had to do
was tell my kids their mother was dead.
Going through Death Cleaning has helped
me become a fuller person.
Life changing!
Thank you!
Look at the screen! They have Landon!
This is not a show about death.
It's about life.
We say that Death Cleaning is for life.
Yes!
So, it's about here and now.
I guess we do have a legacy.
Maybe everyone does, really.
I knew that you guys were going
to declutter my house.
I didn't know you were going to declutter my soul.